music
Wahoo! It's a me! Mercio!
Is it Senpai? Is the game playing at the same time? Are you getting overlapping audio?
You're getting overlapping audio?
Okay. No overlap? No overlap?
Okay.
Okay, no overlap. It's okay.
Attack A.
Let me try to push the game up.
If it's too quiet.
How about now?
No eye patch today?
Now you get both eyes because I am not Mercy Modiste! I am Mercio Mercio!
It's a me!
It's a me! Did I grab this already?
Oh my gosh, they're walking off.
I tuned into the wrong streamer! You're in the right stream! This is exactly where you're supposed to be!
How am I supposed to get that high?
Platforming hard. Platforming not good.
Platforming already? I want this! I want it! I want it! I want it! I want it! I want it!
Hold it!
I want it! I want it! I want it! I want it! I want it! I want it!
And,
what?
Hello?
Good day, my name is Puchinelo Bomb. Puchinelo, never heard of ya.
They say I'm a hothead, but I'll show em. You, you will make me famous.
So long!
Okay.
Penelopeep!
Pelish.
I think Jep will work on him.
I mean fireball won't work on him. He's he's he's uh
He's
Wait, maybe he's weak to fire because he's a bomb, but would bombs also be more powerful with fire
Let's try
Oh
Let's see if this works
It better not be a one again I
Swear if it's a one again friendship cannot be a rock. I will cry
Why do you have so many
Do I hit the micro bomb first
Oh shut the fork off
Oh
Please play a wish
Not bad not bad now. Let's level things up
Why do you have bigger bombs now?
Oh
Yeah
I'm scared. I'm scared. I'm scared actually
I'm scared of these bombs
Please just die
I
I'm GAMING SEMPAI!
That's rude!
How many freaking bombs do you have?
I'm out!
Fuck.
Oh, I'm out.
Oof.
OOF!
AHH!
I'm okay!
Grrr!
Alright, you asked for it!
HOOA!
Excuse me.
I'm gonna need some F.P.
I'm out!
UGH!
Actually, we'll just tap.
Dang it.
Dang it!
OI!
OOF!
UGH!
Wake up!
Thanks!
Come on, Mauo! Wake up! Wake up!
We can't have you do this!
Oh, come on!
Come on!
Get on!
Bite the dust!
Please bite the dust!
I need you!
Who may be, you know, not have a good time!
Oh yeah!
OOF!
UGH!
I must be dreaming! I'm ruined!
I don't want to do this, but now I have no choice.
I think he's bluffing.
Simmer down, Fluffy!
I'm not gonna waste this on you!
Who knows what might happen?
Take your best shot.
Enough! I've got my pride!
Now you're in for it!
Huh? What the hell? Why isn't it working?
OOF!
Mario!
If this thing explodes, we're history!
This is a fine mess.
Let's scram now!
It's gonna blow!
No!
What on earth was that?
Well, we won the battle. I hope we don't lose the war.
Where's dynamite in the star?
I guess that's part of it that's been answered.
Come on, Mario! Hurry!
I can't believe they survived!
Yay! Another star!
How many we got now? Three? Three!
Yeah!
Come on, we still have to find dynamite.
Where the heck am I?
Can I get this yet?
Man!
Ugh! This won't budge! Ugh! I hate this stupid thing!
Help me! Help me here! Give me... Give the mine a car...
Mine car a push!
Care to read the warning? Of course!
Mine car guidelines. Press A to break. Press B to jump.
Get mushrooms and press X to accelerate.
That's a lot of instructions!
Mulville Safety Board MSB.
Yay! A mine car ride! Yippee! This is gonna be fun!
Ah!
Come on!
This is difficult, actually!
Ah! Come on!
Oh!
Are you kidding me?!
I did that!
Oh, come on!
Shit.
Ugh!
I'm dying here, guys! I'm dying here!
I'm dying here!
Oops.
This is a lot.
I can't drive, by the way! This is not the same as driving!
I'm getting dizzy! I'm getting motion sick!
Motion sick!
My mind!
Oh! Oh! Fuck!
Oh, shit!
Oh!
I need the mushrooms!
Come on!
Let's go!
Here we go!
Whoa!
I'm dying here!
Yay! Fireworks!
I wonder how old those kids are doing.
Sure wish they would hurry home.
How old your heart is, Ma?
I asked Ma to help us out.
So I reckon he'll bring him back when he's good and ready.
I just have this odd feeling that they'll be dropping in on us any minute now.
They still gotta use the door like everyone else might now, so down!
We're home!
Gracious! They really did drop in on us!
Oh my poor babies, are you okay?
Little Ma, are you hurt?
Now we're okay, Ma.
Isn't that right, Ma?
We had fun!
He's been knocked senseless, you poor baby.
You're safe now.
Donna, haven't I told you off enough to never go into the mines by yourself?
That's enough, Ma.
Just be happy to have them back.
We haven't thanked Mario proper either.
I'm so embarrassed, Ma.
Mario, we can't thank you enough for everything.
What's that?
The roof, you say?
Nah, don't matter none, right Pa?
It ain't nothing at all.
You just leave any repairs to me.
Give me a hauler if you ever need a hand with your place.
Thanks again for bringing our babies back to us.
You found Dina, Mike, and a star piece.
But where's Peach?
I'm jumping everywhere.
Whee!
Come back, Mr. Beetle.
Don't you want to come to boosters and play?
Yeah, don't run away.
We just want to play.
We don't take good care of you.
Like what he said, okay, Mr. Beetle?
Oi!
No.
Don't you dare touch that babe.
Beetle, it's a present for Booster.
That's right, just hand it over nice and easy.
Yeah, like they said, we won't be your friend.
Booster really, really, really likes Beetles, but he can't catch his own.
That's right, he's busy keeping the princess from the sky entertained.
Oh, we're catching Beetles for him.
So hand it over.
That's right.
Uh, pretty please?
Oh no, it's getting away.
But catch it.
Catch it!
Oh, look, the moles are here.
Welcome to my Purr 10 store.
Would you like a shiny stone?
Sure.
You bring me fireworks, then I'll give you a shiny stone.
Fireworks?
Where can I get fireworks?
Me.
Unnamed.
I call myself Tee, a drink of jam and bread.
Hold on.
Tee, a drink of jam and bread.
Oops, that's not how it really goes.
I'm just bored, but if you go to the mountain, I'll sing you the real song.
Okay, our Mobile Mountain stands at 32566.
Come back and ride it again.
If you try, just go through the inn and rest.
This hole.
This hole, it belongs to me.
It's my hole.
Oh.
Well, Mercio, you could get them to the fireworks factory.
What fireworks factory?
Oh my gosh, is she me?
Welcome Raiders.
Welcome to the stream.
Oh, I mean, oh, welcome.
Welcome Raiders.
Welcome to the stream.
It's me, Mercio.
We are trying to find a page.
Surprise.
Oh, I'm so shocked.
I'm so shocked.
Wow, what a surprise.
Welcome, Raiders.
Chibi, did you beat the big boss?
Not the bad Mario.
What are you talking about?
This is the real Mario.
This is the real Mario voice.
I am not the Mario.
This is Mercio.
I am the Mercio.
We are playing the Mario RPG.
This is the real Mercio here.
You can't tell me otherwise.
This is not Mercimogees.
This is Mercio, Mercio.
Look at it.
It's real in my hat.
What does it stand for?
Mercio.
And it's for Mercy.
Look at me, I do the jump.
It's fun, okay?
Take a joke.
Does that make us the princess in another castle?
You're all my princesses now and I must save you all.
Well, welcome.
I'm so glad you're here.
What a surprise.
Not that I made some suspicious sounds
in your chat or anything.
Speaking of...
I put back batteries into my automaton.
Now I am a menace to society.
Menace sounds like me.
It sounds like me.
Senpai.
Thank you, joke R, for the 420.
Wouldn't this be a Louisbee raven?
Um, Louisbee.
Louisbee, come on.
Ah, Louisbee.
Mercio and Louisbee superstar.
I don't know if she's gonna hate me or love me for that.
I love her.
Well, welcome.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, Shibi, for the raid.
Welcome in.
We are playing Mario RPG.
I have gotten three stars already.
Shibi's a taller one, so it makes sense.
I mean, yeah.
Somebody, oh wait, and then that means like...
I see would be Peach.
And then...
I don't know who to assign who.
Bowser can be...
Emmie?
No, Emmie's told, yeah.
Emmie's told, and then Bowser can be...
Azura.
Azura, and then...
What other Mario characters are there?
Bowser.
Strony is something.
Yoshi?
Daisy?
Strony.
I mean, Strony has...
As Yoshi sounds pretty cute.
Strow sheet, no.
No, never mind.
That sounds so bad.
Hahaha.
I mean, Yoshi lays eggs, right?
And technically, Strony laid...
I mean, laid?
Uh, Barthed, all of us, right?
Hahaha.
Technically.
Therefore...
It is correct.
Welcome, Sam, to Snippin' Him Out Here!
This logic is sound.
Yes, I agree. Give me a second, though.
Yes, yes.
Flawless logic!
This hole, my wife dug, is a shortcut to the trolley.
Does it mean it's going to ride, and I am named a Mobile Mountain?
Name that nifty.
Drop in here, and you'll be right at the trolley track.
It'll cost you 10 coins.
Asgore is, uh...
Oh, yeah, it's, uh, 32566.
Do you want to ride or not? No.
Be that way!
I thought she was winking at us.
There you go.
Right? 10 coins feels like Kai-Way robbery.
You heard?
There's a rumor that Booster's new girlfriend fell from the sky.
She's supposed to be pretty, too, just like a princess.
Now, now, who would have thought a girl could fall out of the sky?
Maybe it's Princess Peach.
Nah.
It's Princess Peach.
Check out Booster's tower!
It's filled with neat stuff!
My eyes are off gossiping again. She's been gone for hours.
You like fireworks? I'm like a mom.
Own invention right now.
I've only got sparklers down my hand and giving up.
Want to buy 100, 500 coins?
Yeah.
Thanks.
Yeah, just wait for my masterpiece.
I'm back with one point.
Coins by my inventions, okay?
Alright, got fireworks.
Yeah, now I can get that shiny stone!
Here you go.
Welcome to my pretend store.
Would you like a shiny stone? Yeah.
I'm going to trade you for your fireworks.
Yeah.
Thank you. Please come again.
Got shiny stone.
I don't even know what it does.
Is it just Purdy?
Is she just Purdy?
Hold on.
No, wait. What's the menu?
There we go.
Hoop-a-chill.
I have no idea what the shiny stone...
shiny, shiny stone does.
Oh, thank you, Fiendish,
for gifting 10 members.
Thank you.
You know Booster?
He's the weirdo living in the tower.
A little ways from here.
Come on in. You're the talk of town.
They say that you save the kids.
What do you need?
What do I need?
Oh shit, I have no coins!
Wait, I spent it all!
I spent it all!
On the rock!
I wanted the rock!
Where's the rock?
Where's even the rock?
I'm so hungry, wish I had a Carbo Cookie.
Welcome to my pretend store.
Would you like a shiny stone?
No items left. Thank you. Please come again.
It's dried, I'm so worried about it.
Okay, so I can trade it for...
in the mole girls?
You can't get inside Booster's tower very easily.
You need a really strong person for that.
I want a nice shiny stone.
I'll trade it for my Carbo Cookie.
Okay, gracious.
Here you go.
Carbo Cookie.
Thank you for the mines.
I opened some neat stuff and I opened up a minor store.
Come and take a look at what I got to sell.
Item number one, a lucky jewel.
I'm sure to bring you plenty of good luck.
I'll sell it to you for 100 coins.
You need more coins, I gotta eat, you know?
That's all I got for now.
Man!
Okay.
Oh, you have a Carbo Cookie.
I'm so hungry, may I have it please?
Oh, thanks, sister.
You're so nice, I'll give you the screen coin.
That's all I got!
Man.
I feel like I've been ripped, like, actually.
I can't believe that I really got ripped off.
He missed it, did you ride on my paws, trolley?
He says I'm too young to ride it.
I feel like...
I need to get another shiny stone, yeah.
Mercy, without the eye patch, what are you talking about?
I'm Mercy L!
See?
Oh, 500!
I feel so ripped off!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh!
Ally!
I'm never doing that again.
Oh.
I need more money now.
Money!
Hey, booster pass!
I only got one.
Platforming hard!
Hey, was there cool stuff over there?
Hold on.
Would you like a sack of gold?
Is it better than a sack of...
shit?
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm trying to find places.
But yes, I would always love gold.
Why are they...
in there?
Was I supposed to do something there?
Oh my gosh!
It's Bowser!
Booster has such a nice place.
I miss my fortress.
Wait, Booster has such a nice place.
Miss the good old days.
Peach screaming in terror.
Mario rushing in to save her.
Oh!
Look!
He likes us.
Oh, Jesus, Mario!
Oops, okay, okay, calm down.
Don't let him see you like this.
Hey, I win.
He has a crush on us.
Admit it, he has a crush on us.
Just, hey, how you doing?
He's being so Sunday.
No, not like that dummy wrong tone.
He needs more confidence.
You!
What are you doing here?
If Peach were on my castle waiting to be rescued,
she'd be crying like a baby.
Oh!
Did I just hear some...
Did I hear some voices?
It couldn't be.
I can't believe it.
It's Mario.
Mario!
I'm up here!
That voice is Peach.
I thought she got away,
but she's stuck there.
Well, I guess I'll be
returning to my castle now.
Out of my way, Shorty!
Wait, okay, that's a good Peach voice.
But you don't like my other voices?
I think they're great.
It's locked.
What's the matter?
The door's not opening or something?
He's so cute.
He's helping!
Yeah, I'm a piece of work, ain't I?
Whoa, hold up.
We've got to stop the way inside now, huh?
You doing okay?
As well?
Can you do a mercy impression?
Oh, this power end looks too.
I know, I know, you're thinking.
A big, strong guy like him
would be great to get along, right?
I'm gonna do something. I may regret later.
I'll let you join my minions.
You can thank me later.
Mario and his friends have joined
Bowser's minions.
Or so they're pretending.
Bowser joined the group!
Oh, that's so cute!
Would you like an explanation on how to switch allies?
Yes, please.
No!
I can't remember what Toad's voice is like.
I can't remember Toad's voice.
What did I do?
Now you're a four, but fighting's limited to three!
I don't know.
Access party now!
What am I doing?
These three will fight!
But their pals rest!
Simply choose the two!
It's not correct!
You wish to switch!
Mario must always fight though!
When you succeed at several...
At several action commands in a row!
In ally buff!
The buff is different for each ally in the battle!
Only the bonus for active party members
will be in effect!
Try it out!
Try it with other party members to see what you get!
I can't remember!
Should I go train myself?
Should I go train first?
I'm worried.
If I'm supposed to be level eight.
Oh there! Booster's busy right now!
So he can't play!
I'll make some other time where you can try to force your way in!
Alright!
I can do that too!
Oh!
What the heck is that?
Damn!
Okay! Shit!
I'm sorry! I wasn't familiar with your game!
Yeah!
Orb user!
Hey!
Hey! Senpai! Are you pondering your orb?
Yeah!
Sniff it!
Orb user!
Oh the orb is weak!
Yeah!
What's your special?
Carorize!
Right!
Like that?
Oh! It worked!
Ah!
Mid mushroom!
It's not as good as the greatest mushrooms!
Level up!
Mario reach level eight!
What should I do?
Physical? Magic?
I want to do physical.
Alright!
Alright! Get back here!
Can I do a triple move?
Oh!
I'm testing what it looks like!
How nice!
Yay! New friendship move!
It's back here!
Yay!
Was that just a seesaw?
Or could I fight them?
Booster the first?
Jester!
I don't like the way you look!
You remind me of someone!
Oh shit!
There we go!
Hmm?
Hello!
Thank you!
Oh! I got it!
I got it!
Ooh!
Are you scared?
Look at that! I'm getting better!
Oh look!
I'll also reach level eight!
You're getting everything in magic!
I'm sorry!
Booster the fourth!
Booster the fifth!
Booster the sixth!
I literally dodged all of them, huh?
What's the big rush?
I'm Booster!
And this is my famous Tower of Amusement!
Normally I welcome visitors to play with me and my sniffsters.
However, a girl fell out of the sky and into my lap recently.
Since then I've been busy keeping her happy and entertained.
I no longer have time to play,
so please enjoy yourself at your own risk, that is.
That's...
Very polite!
Found a flower tab!
Where the fuck do you go?
Please, you're fading from bothering Booster!
Let's work on my timing.
Yeah!
Hold on, I really want to know what that...
What that, you know...
Sorry.
I'm passing through.
I don't know.
Are those Bob-omb goals?
Is it really just...
Is it really just, you know,
seesawing?
Can I set them off?
Try from higher up.
I feel like we can jump higher.
I don't know how to jump higher.
Don't worry about it for now, okay.
I know, he just wants a friend to play seesaw.
Oh, I'm stuck.
This theme is so nice.
Dollocks!
Dolls!
Nice.
P-Jump.
Hell-O-Ice.
Stop running away, wait a second.
Over here.
I can't jump high enough for this!
This is so rude.
Or can you, can I?
Senpai's.
I failed.
You still like me even if I failed, right?
Even if I'm a failure, you still like me, right?
Senpai's.
Even if I'm clumsy and pawn, you still love me, right?
Okay, I'm gonna try this again.
Senpai's.
I miss!
Again!
Senpai's.
Senpai, thank you for the two super chat. Do I really have a choice?
Yeah, even though it's the illusion of choice, you have a choice. This might not be the greatest...
Wait, it is the greatest choice. What are you talking about? What are you trying to say?
This is a lot of people.
This is a lot of people!
Senpai's.
There you go!
Yeah, I leveled up!
I think most of them are magic or is he more physical?
Yeah, he's good with magic I think.
Yeah.
Okay, one more time. I can do it.
I'm not even going to say anything.
That didn't happen.
Oh shit, I don't have anything.
Yeah, you cost too much. Slap him.
Kill the arm!
Bitch slap!
Whiskey no.
Attack up, okay.
Yes, I did it!
Pick me up and put pick me up in the storage box.
Oh, I don't have enough items.
I swear.
Okay, which left? This left, right?
Wait, maybe? No, no, I can't.
Okay, we're on the yellow.
We're slightly to the left on the yellow, correct?
This is where we drop, right?
Let's go!
I'll jump next time!
I can't be this bad, right?
This is a trap, right?
This can't be, right?
I can't be this bad, right?
What the hell?
How did that work?
The game really took me on me.
Is that a new weapon? Is that a good weapon?
Massure. Oh, actually, yeah.
Let's just take the win. I'm taking it right now!
Nobody can stop me! This is my win!
This is my first time! This is my win!
What was that loud noise outside? Check out the booster pass!
Oh! Oh my goodness! Senpai, it's raining quite a bit!
Hold on. Oh, that's a lot of rain, hold on.
Senpai!
Thank you for the 333! You're so good, the game just gave up!
Shut up.
I know! It might be another storm approaching. I can feel the hell shaking a bit.
How did I do that? How did I? How did I do that?
It doesn't sound like thunder so far. Let's try this out.
Look at me! Bitch slap.
Please, no thunder today. Ah, shit. Ah, shit, never mind.
Oh no, that's thunder! That's really loud. Oh no.
Oh no, do I have to end early again?
Yeah, I can feel the house and I just heard that huge thunder.
Mother nature, why?
I don't know if you can hear it, Senpai.
Oh no.
Like, I can literally hear like the glass is shaking and stuff. Oh man.
No!
It sounded really close, Senpai.
You sound...
Give me a second Senpai, will you let me see outside?
I'm gonna go see outside and then we'll see if...
Wait, shit, I haven't had a save point yet. You're right, I don't have a save point yet.
I'm gonna go see and then we're gonna see if we have a save point.
I'm gonna go see outside, okay? B-R-B, Senpai!
I'm gonna go see outside.
It is literally flashing.
Senpai!
Thank you for the two, Griffin, and thank you for the two, Boy.
It's pretty bad, it looks like...
It looks like, you know, like the fighting scenes in Yu-Yu Hakusho where it's like flashing lights everywhere?
It's like, it's like that.
Like, it's bad, bad.
So, let's go back to Motown.
We'll save.
I'm gonna wait out the weather.
Oh, wait, shit, that's the wrong room.
It's just still far off.
Like if you...
It's pretty bad.
Okay, so...
Yeah, it looks like someone's having a shonen battle out there, like it's flashing lights everywhere.
I can hear the thunder, like, booming.
So, yeah, I'm gonna...
Let's go to Just Chatting, I'll give you guys a little rundown, and then we'll go...
I always hate it when this happens!
Okay, so it's always the fireworks, silly.
Yeah, uh...
Senpai!
There's no way there's gonna be fireworks right now.
So, okay, this sucks!
This sucks!
This really sucks!
Normally, my area doesn't get like really bad thunderstorms like this, but recently it's been like pretty, pretty, pretty, you know...
It's happening a lot.
So, let's go over my schedule.
If the rain ends quickly, Senpai, I will come back and do a gorilla stream.
If it's not too late.
If it's not too late, it will, um...
I will do a gorilla stream.
Senpai!
But, like, looking outside right now, it literally is like an epilepsy, like, warning.
It's an epilepsy warning, basically.
Thank you, Kisato Daiju, for the five super chat.
I mean, I get to play more out in ring, but, like, I want to hang out with Kohai for four plus hours.
Me, too!
But, like, it seriously looks like, you know, like, it's really, it's really bad right now.
And I can hear the storm and stuff, so hopefully, um, I'm probably gonna end this stream just for safety reasons.
Um, yeah, it's pretty much the Pikachu outside trying to ruin childhoods.
Uh, if I don't come back, tomorrow is the...
Okay, we'll speed this up.
Uh, tomorrow is the membership only screen, which is SMT Nocturne.
If you have membership tier at the member tier, uh, you can join, you can join and watch it.
If you don't, uh, please upgrade.
Um, on Saturday, I have a collab with, sort of, my best game, Serenity Cosmica.
Uh, we're playing Takoyaki Party, but yeah, uh, I'm a yeet.
I'm a go now.
I'm so sorry, senpai.
I really wanted to stay with you more, but holy cow, is, is it, like, going crazy?
Okay, so, let me see if there's anyone on to redirect you to.
Little, little, little, little, little, little, little.
Let's do...
Meal?
I don't see anyone on.
Yeah, let's do a meal.
And let's save.
So, I'll see you guys again soon, okay?
Scream for Mercy!
Wah!